la cathédrale jean linard un site à
l'abandon où il y as mais pâtissier sur
le secteur un jour sa campagne lui
propose une visite les deux jeunes gens
tombent sous le charme
donc elle m'a montré ce lieu est mon
grand étonnement un autre grand
étonnement c'était fermé et
on s'est permis de rêver cinq minutes
c'est de se dire mais on peut contribuer
à refaire vivre ce lieu en la cathédrale
de jean linard est fermée au public
depuis deux ans son prix de vente a été
baissé de moitié de 430 mille euros il
est passé à 210 mille euros will i am et
sa famille ont alors décidé de l'acheter
mais il y a des difficultés
jean ménard a créé sa de de sa main il
n'a pas fait ça dans dans les dents les
normes et le bâtiment
est fragile et du coup les banques ont
peur de cette fragilité et ne veulent
pas prendre le risque d'investir de
l'argent dans un lieu qui demande autant
de travaux et d'investissements
personnels pendant ce temps la famille
de l'artiste décédé en 2010 et dans la
tente de son côté la fille de jean
linard aurait préféré qu'un organisme
public achète ce patrimoine c'est une
volonté de base est que ce soit une
institution dans l'idée que ce soit
public en fait voilà que ce soit ça
appartiennent au public c'était aussi le
désir de mon père voilà après
faut que ce lieu vive quoi donc
effectivement un projet privé peut être
très moteur aussi quoi pour le lieu mais
pour ça il faudra patienter l'oeuvre de
jean linard n'est pas encore sauvé